I just got ghosted so hard recently  oh it was it was gnarly  because it hurt my feelings because the  date and we made a plan to meet up that  weekend and felt like oh this is there's  something here maybe yeah um which I  know from like one date that sounds  psycho no it doesn't it does not at all  I've met people and been like you were  put on the earth for me you know I'm not  sure I was investing that much but I  definitely thought and also we hate him  because he goes to do so I called my  therapist Barry which I know sounds  bougie and that's not it Barry is like  one of the most high road thinking  people I've ever met and I was speaking  to him and I was just saying God I just  missed that Jack Berger Post-It note we  all vilified him in Sex in the City for  the Post-it note I'm sorry I can't don't  hate me and this was the bad guy this  guy in this day and age would be a  freaking saint